we want to welcome to the program Rona
fields who is the co-author of this book
along with several other contributors
called martyrdom the psychology theology
and politics of self-sacrifice good
morning good morning why do people kill
themselves for a cause
well they don't kill themselves for
cause if they're going to be martyrs
they're killed for a cause mmm but
that's that's a question to I the whole
issue of what is a martyr is the
question that set off and required a
whole book to answer and and it isn't
answered I mean the question is still
alive
in fact the second part of the book is a
conversation amongst the contributors
and one is a theologian one is a
professor of literature and one is the
political Australian and me who's a
psychologist and sociologist
well in that conversation you say quote
members of terror organizations identify
only with their own group they live in a
we versus they cosmos and if they are
dictators or leaders of insurgent groups
declare that a good death is the death
perceive for and that a bad death is
when one of their own is killed then you
ask this question can we relate this
phenomenon to the biblical
interpretations on the choice of life or
death yes and that's probably the most
critical question about which this book
concerns itself the issue of choice I
think one of the things I heard the
issue that with which I start out the
book is the neuropsychology of choice
behavior it's particularly appropriate
today and on Memorial weekend because
memory plays a very large part and the
choice process and one of the bases for
the determination that
this is a cause is through the like
little icons in the brain connected with
various memories first of all martyrdom
is a concept it's not a definition as
such as a concept it is developed out of
a number of ideas and the ideas come
together in various ways and one of the
things I was trying to accomplish with
this book is to show how these ideas
coming together under various cultural
time and theological perspectives have
merged into the idea of martyrdom or
diverged into different kinds of
martyrdom and historically of course we
we could we could start with the
beginning of human beings because
sacrifice has been part of the ritual of
human beings but the evolution from
human sacrifice to animal sacrifice to
self sacrifice and by self-sacrifice I'm
including self-denial and prolongation
of of suffering for a greater cause this
self sacrifice so you see it's het it
has a history but the word itself word
itself comes from the Greek martyr
meaning witness and interestingly enough
there's no such word in Aramaic which is
the origin of course of Hebrew and
Arabic and although some would say there
were martyrs in Judaism pre Christianity
they are not identified as such but let
me get to the essence of
what we saw on September 11th wow you
had these individuals who killed
themselves for a cause or what we see on
regular occasions on the west front of
the Gaza Strip inside Israel by
Palestinians who obviously have this
anger toward the Israelis and toward the
West
and you say in the book voluntary death
suicide incorporates two significant
symbols power and purity and then you
say that a cosmic war carries the
symbolism of sacrifice and martyrdom the
origins of suicide homicide are found in
the practices of the 12th and 13th
century Islamic sect yes but then I say
afterward actually a couple hundred
years earlier under pope urban ii
crusaders were told that if they died in
the war for the holy land all their
venal sins would be forgiven and they
would ascend immediately to heaven
so what's our message in this is this is
the harder part um I think the message
is that behavior whether it's
self-sacrifice by hunger strike or the
belief in a cause to the point of being
willing to die for it is all a a choice
behavior accept accept and this is where
the 911 comes in in the immature brain
and the immature moral development which
is around the time of adolescents
usually the world is seen in black and
white as described there it's us in them
and vendetta is the message generally
people develop beyond that point and
it's important in order to have a
democratic society for there to be moral
development beyond that point when
somebody who's not a psychologist isn't
it in your human instinct to want to
survive I mean
the end of the day why would anyone kill
themselves for any reason if they
believe that they will achieve something
through their deaths that they can't
achieve through their life and that is
the suicide homicide that is not
necessarily the martyr in in general
terms Jean d'Arc for instance and and
her pictures on the cover of the book as
well as the the suicide homicide Jean
d'Arc had a belief um
religious belief a spiritual belief an
idea she did not want to martyr herself
she did not want to be martyred she was
willing to compromise in her behavior
but not in her belief and she died
believing not wanting to die there is
the example of the Western idea of the
martyr and interestingly enough at the
time she wasn't accepted by anybody as a
martyr and certainly not as a saint and
she was described variously at the time
as heretic Shakespeare even called her a
[ __ ] and she for many hundreds of years
was a figure of question for the French
a figure of derision for the English and
today she's the icon and symbol of
political parties ranging from the far
left to the far right and each one finds
in her something that's iconic the
memory of her the idea she evokes in the
brains of those who
um idealize differs from one to another
the suicide homicide becomes ascribed a
murder in their society ascribed to
murder through the idealization that
occurs after their death not the ideals
of their life their death is idealized
and this is this is quite the opposite
and that's why I have these two
opposites on the cover
our guest is Rona fields who is the
author of martyr dumps and background
she is a graduate of Lake Forest College
earned her master's at Loyola University
and University of Southern California
she has taught at Clark University
George Mason University California State
Cal State Long Beach and Pasadena City
College our phone lines are open you can
also email us at journal at c-span org
the numbers 2 0 to 5 8 5 38 81 if you
support President Bush into 0 to 5 8 5
3880 if you support the Democrats our
first call is from Roxboro North
Carolina good morning yes they standard
one I just want to say an interesting
take on the conversation here it's
amazing how people will leaders
religious leaders world leaders will use
religion to persuade the masses to
follow their our particular decisions
that they make you know we look at that
recently you're out on Khomeini and
other Arab leaders call us the Great
Satan in the 70s and the 80s and you
know some of the Lada negative thing
reference in the nineties and then of
course you know the war against
communism and when we asserted our
judeo-christian faith and it was a
battle versus Cooper's have been good
versus evil and also as recent as our
president bush you know relatedness is
out of love good versus evil
and that I just want to get by you see
the lady's comments on that I parallel
there and how people
which I'm a Christian I'm a strong
Christian my belief and I'm thankful for
our president who is not ashamed of his
fate but how that is twisted and turned
for political and other reasons I'm
going to listen thank you thank you
well I think I think that um the concept
of martyrdom is one of the concepts that
can be twisted and turned for political
purposes and I think in the book I go to
great lengths and so does my colleague
Valerie Russell to explain how the idea
can be hijacked just as the planes
airplanes were hijacked on on September
11th but the the point is that it's it's
an idea that lends itself to building
cohesion amongst a group and in that
sense not only can it be hijacked by
those who want to rationalize their
behavior and it has been by everyone
from bin Laden to peanut ship it's been
a term that's been hijacked he describes
himself as a murder as well and um but
you see that the issue is not
necessarily a religious one in the
French national ideal it's been used
it's been used it's been used at nauseam
unfortunately so that we've lost track
of what is a martyr did you talk to some
of the family members of these martyrs
yes I did and what did they tell you
well actually one of my colleagues is
Palestinian and in a study that led up
to this book that preceded the book at
this book sin other books had actually
used psychological tests postmortem
and gotten the answers from members of
the families of those who had committed
homicide suicide in Gaza in the 90s
during the time of the Oslo Accords now
what these families explained about and
and what was different about the young
people who committed it at the time and
you have to realize that the time is
very very important in accounting for
martyrdom the time period and the other
influences at that period there was only
one instigator for this kind of behavior
and that was hummus preceding that
Hezbollah had instituted this kind of
behavior they had to fit it with their
theological constructs which revolved
around two things the purpose of jihad
to legitimately attack and do do damage
to anyone who is an infidel occupying of
Islamic or Muslim land and the other was
to glorify if you will their cause okay
so this was legitimacy and in many cases
the parents didn't understand that their
children their young people were
involved in this and many times the
parents were not even particularly
religious at in the beginning but and
many of the people in the 90s who did
this were in a sense
marginal they were unemployed they
weren't under educated they had other
concerns that they needed to
fulfill by taking this direction some of
them were well the ones in the 90s were
extremely fervent Islamists and and very
frustrated professor the book is called
martyrdom the psychology theology and
politics of self-sacrifice our next call
for Rona fields is Amherst New Hampshire
good morning
go ahead New Hampshire you're on c-span
we'll try York Pennsylvania good morning
to you good morning how are you fine
thank you
okay I'm calling with falling question
primarily the Israelis are armed to the
teeth with sophisticated weapons tanks
smart bombs killer copters guided
missiles they have completely with gun
control defeated the Palestinians we've
been having a pistol except illegally
otherwise okay if you were a Palestinian
and your mother and father were killed
by Israeli rockets what would you do and
you turn around and have nothing the
Israelis have armored vest and what have
you and two million dollar tanks that we
gave I actually sold them indirectly but
what would you do what we courses they
have Thank You caller that's one of the
things I took up in several places in
the book but particularly out of my
studies in Lebanon after the after the
massacre and 1982-83 I had gone into
Sabra and Shatila and examined survivors
and I found some various attitudes and
ways of dealing with what had happened
one of them was amongst some of the
young boys aged 13 to 15 vaguely
generally these boys considered
themselves to have a mission they were
feeling guilty because many of them had
rejected the compulsory military
training that was part of the
Palestinian requirement for all kids
from age 6 on they were not exactly
unarmed but kids being kids
some of them rebelled against that so
when the massacre happened they were
feeling very guilty and they were
feeling like they had honor to reclaim
four of these adolescents within four
years became the perpetrators of the
horrendous shootouts in the rome in
Vienna Airport where they shot and
killed helpless bystanders including
Americans American children on the other
hand I also interviewed many adults many
other people I interviewed a woman who
left one of the most profound impacts of
any on me she had lost 11 members of her
family and she sat on the floor with her
two surviving children one on each side
and she described what had happened she
described it in the flat tones of
someone who is still
in acute stress and when she was
finished she said do you have any other
questions and I could really taste my
Cheers
and I said yes how do you get up in the
morning and she put her hands out in
front of her and she said Ella this
woman had chosen her belief to keep
going and that's a long way of answering
your question I know but it's a matter
of choice behavior you can choose
vendetta or you can choose to go on and
take care of life and that was an
example there's another example in the
book I spent about a week with Khmer
Rouge and during that time I met some of
the most horrific kinds of twisted and
contorted psychological consequences to
their their system of upbringing
children never knew when they were going
to get praised you're punished they
never knew what behavior would evoke
what kind of response but I met one
fourteen-year-old and who I asked as
I've guessed when I've tested all of
these people they're they're thousands
now from all over the world we've been
in my study from from the time I wrote
this book on Northern Ireland until
until today I met one the
fourteen-year-old and I asked him what
he wanted to do when he grew up and he
said I want to be a doctor I said where
did you get that idea
because there were no doctors I mean
they didn't believe in doctors
if you got hurt you got whatever part it
was chopped off and that was it
but in a refugee camp he had met some a
team of French doctors and he was
fascinated with their mission to save
lives and he pointed around at the other
people to me and he said look do you see
that in that net
and he pointed to people who were
obvious amputees who had horrible
disfiguring scars and their faces really
really human wreckage and I said yes I
see and he said that's why I want to be
a doctor next call for rona fields is
from Washington DC good morning
I wondered if miss fields took this
theory to its conclusion in America
I'm psychologists in Washington and and
I'm actually writing a book as well
about adolescent psychology and how
America has come to the point in its
economic life where we really could live
a very peaceful and peaceful and and
fulfilling life except we have this
martyrdom complex and in Freudian
psychology it has a lot to do with not
getting past adolescents and not
choosing adulthood with because we we
don't have any figures any leaders any
examples to follow the thank you for the
call
yes I've certainly I certainly had ample
opportunity to examine the adolescent
psyche in the United States I do a lot
of my work with clinical work with
adolescents in DC and the culture the
contemporary American culture emphasizes
vendetta
rather than choice of behavior and and I
think that contributes unfortunately to
large incidents well to the incidence of
school shootings for example to the
incidence of gang wars and I think it is
also contributed to the way some of our
soldiers have had a rationale a
rationale for committing torture on
helpless prisoners we are unfortunately
living at a time of popular culture for
favoring this adolescent developmental
stage of Vendetta
the book is called martyrdom the
psychology theology and politics of
self-sacrifice one last point one
persons martyr is another person's
terrorist correct or not do you know
that brings up the whole issue that a
lot of my colleagues right now are
saying anyone can be a torture anyone
can be a terrorist I don't think so
I think that there is I think that there
is an absolute on this and the absolute
is through choice granted people who
have not developed the frontal lobes the
executive function in the brain in the
brain to the full mature capacity
children who have not been educated to
think in these terms but Mahatma Gandhi
and Martin Luther King if you examine
their upbringing you see that they could
never have been terrorists Rhona fields
on that note thank you very much for
joining us thank you for having me we
will continue with your phone calls and
also look at some of the stories in the
morning newspapers too
inside the Washington Post more on Iraq
and the June 30th deadline US officials
and a UN envoy